after opening during the pandemic local
restaurant vegas test kitchen is
celebrating its first anniversary this
saturday with a food festival why not
here to tell us more is jolene the
founder of vegas test kitchen last time
i hung out with you
it was at your restaurant during mardi
gras so i know first hand these guys
know how to party okay we do love
throwing parties so
and this is really special for us
because we've made it a year i chose
exciting during such a you know
important time too absolutely we
encourage our restaurants and our in our
chefs so you guys are doing something
really special for the community let's
let's introduce nina
hi i'm nina
so nina mancha is um she owns forte
tapas she also started banishka which
was inside of the vegas test kitchen so
she was one of the first seven chefs to
be a part of our opening okay so for
this event she hasn't been with us for a
few months before the event we have a
few of our you know first-time chefs
coming back to celebrate with us and
give everybody a little bit of taste
like what she used to serve yeah which
we all miss because we love this dish so
also the one year anniversary of you now
being able to pronounce the name
it only took you two years
her whole entire menu was difficult
before we get to that cheesy dish that i
cannot wait to bite into explain the
concept of vegas test kitchen because
this is really special so we're we're a
multi-concept restaurant um we opened
during the pandemic to
uh give chefs a place to test menu
options uh almost like an incubator for
them right and um the whole concept
itself was a test to see if it would
work so i'm happy to say that we've
we've had you know 30 plus chefs come
through the through the kitchen between
pop-ups and being sort of residents
selling to selling to the community so
it's um it's been really rewarding i
love that and nina now let's get to your
dish so what do you bring to the table
literally and figuratively so this is
banitza um and we named it banichka
because that's just a cute way of saying
the pastry if you go to bulgaria you'll
find stands like carrying this different
types of versions of this pastry all
over the place so i wanted to expose
people to it even if they can't
pronounce the name every time someone
bit into it they enjoy it it's basically
cheese butter that over here peel a
dough
an egg
okay so while i taste this yeah how
about you explain how people can help
you celebrate on saturday yeah so we'll
have 13 chefs coming some past tenants
some current chefs at the test kitchen
we're gonna do all day food festival so
it's the vtk food fest we'll be open
from 12 to eight we're located on east
fremont right next to ferguson's
downtown it's celebrating their two
years i was gonna say it's sort of like
a block party down there because
ferguson's is turning two we're turning
one it'll be live music food everywhere
family friendly dog friendly just a
really good time it's a big block party
yeah i love it and what i love most
about you guys is the amazing food it's
a community it's a family absolutely so
where can people find more information
this is delicious by the way yeah yeah
i'm going to test kitchen.com look at
the calendar look at the event page you
can go to secretburger.com and also rsvp
if you want to it's not required but
that will put you into a raffle to win
some natural wine
so it's up to you yeah well thank you so
much jolene nina
this is delicious i love this a bulgia